secretary Alejandro mayorkas facing
increased calls for impeachment from
lawmakers on Capitol Hill Republicans in
purple districts are feeling the
pressure as illegals Trek into the U.S
at record rates our next guest has gone
toe-to-toe with DHS head with the DHS
head in the past and now he's calling to
take away his salary until he fulfills
his oath Texas Congressman chip Roy
joins us now Congressman great to have
you on the program
interesting and good that so much
attention has been focused on Alejandra
mayorcas and potentially perhaps some
accountability and not to be a pessimist
Congressman but I do want to ask you
this let's say that the goals were
accomplished in majorcus were impeached
would that change anything because the
policies come don't they from his boss
they come from Joe Biden
well there's no question that President
Biden Bears the uh responsibility for
the chaos of the border and of course
what does he do he hops on an airplane
and flies to Japan even while he then
claims that the sky is falling that
there's going to be default on her debt
uh they're profoundly unserious about
the problems facing our nation but
Alejandro mayorkas is the tip of the
spear this is a guy who stood up and
lied he lied to the American people
about border patrol agents the people
who report to him claiming that they
were whipping Haitian migrants and
saying it was systemic racism he knew
that was a lot he lied to me under oath
he lied to me he said they have
operational control of the border and
then he just dismisses it in subsequent
hearings he has a duty to enforce the
law and he's blatantly disregarding that
Duty and American citizens are dying I
met with three fentanyl moms just two
weeks ago three of the dozens hundreds
actually fentanyl moms that I've met
with over the last two years who've lost
their children and loved ones to
fentanyl fentanyl pouring across our
border being promoted by China and
dangerous cartels while this
Administration ignores him enough of
course we should impeach him I can't say
what the Senate's going to do the Senate
and the president they don't want to
defend this country but we're the house
we're led by Republicans and we should
impeach my orcas yeah our Banner below
you says gain steam you says we you say
we should you point out the house does
have control what is the likelihood what
is the of leadership in the house saying
we agree with you let's move it
I think there's some uh considered
movement going on a few of the guys that
have been a little more questioning
whether we should or shouldn't do it
recognize that when you have somebody
that's a cabinet official who lies the
American people and dangers the American
people and disregards his own to the
Constitution that that is why High
crimes and misdemeanors exist a breach
of the public trust if you go back and
read the founders so I think we're
heading in that direction I think we
should do it this week uh but I I
certainly hope we will get there over
the next couple of months and I'm
encouraging my Republican colleagues to
do so the American people need need to
see us fight for them they need to see
us stand up when you've got an
Administration ignoring the law now
we've got chaos at the border we still
have 4 000 a day we had 200 000 in April
and thank goodness Governor Abbott and
Texans have DPS down at the border with
razor wire doing the job that the border
patrol agents aren't allowed to do by
this Administration they want to but
they're not allowed to and thank God
Governors like Governor DeSantis are
sending uh support in the form of
national Guardsmen and and their own law
enforcement to help Texas deal with what
the Federal government should do yeah
there's dozens of satellite offices
along the border to just keep processing
that's one of the reasons why we're not
there's they can claim that there's a
decrease they're just continuing the
processing and speeding that up you know
one of the people who brought the
attention on the border and said we
could actually fix it and did it was
Donald Trump
um and he you know he said it with the
wall it was very unpopular when he did
it but you're supporting Ron DeSantis
talk to us about how you made that
decision because I know that you did
like Donald Trump
yeah I was a big fan of America First
agenda president Trump uh took on the
swamp and the swamp bit back and I think
a lot of it's been unfair the the Durham
report of what we saw was absolutely
mind-boggling the FBI weaponized against
the American people but I think we need
to go forward in a Direction with a
governor that has shown that he can
serve first of all for eight years but
he has shown that he can win a broadcast
coalition
he won 62 percent of Hispanic voters he
won 50 of single female voters showed
that you can take on the corporate
establishment conditions
that recognizes that success is
attainable and something that you can do
if you seek to do it but you got to
build a coalition to make that happen
and Governor census is a friend a proven
conservative and uh look I think he's
showing day by day what you can do this
legislative session in Florida has been
extraordinary go down the checklist of
what they've done Universal school
choice a booming economy uh they've got
strong uh you know immigration and
border security measures like e-verify
and making sure that they are enforcing
the laws in Florida so I think this is
the leadership we need and can serve
eight years to carry this country
forward to beat back the swamp and take
it back from the establishment
it's all good stuff down in Florida but
he's got to get past Trump and his base
in the process we shall see uh chip Roy
thank you for being with us thank you